it is day six of the search and rescue  operation at the condo collapse in  florida  authorities have notified the families  of 11 victims but at least 150 are still  missing  search and rescue operations look for  life in the massive  mound of rubble it continued throughout  the night throughout the morning  there are currently 210 people for  working  on the mound president biden will visit  the community on thursday  to console families we'll have more  details on that coming up in our next  half hour at 4  30. several bay area rescue workers are  heading to south florida to lend a  helping hand in the recovery efforts  among the team is this dog here named  force and  their handler driver engineer brittany  bishop  they will be part of a four dog team  that is joining forces with tampa's fire  rescue  who are also deploying staff to surfside  to help find victims